[Music]
there it is handshake gate the
controversy that has become one of the
silliest that i can ever remember but
i'm grateful for it because it's given
us plenty of things to talk about today
richard sherman claims that he was
snubbed by baker mayfield the
indisputable visual evidence clearly and
obviously proves otherwise we'll hear
from baker mayfield today maybe we'll
hear from richard sherman either on
twitter or in the locker room in san
francisco but that has inspired chris
our wednesday pft live draft and the
question is this the dumbest nfl
controversy of all time and look it can
go a lot of different ways i guess you
have a trivia question for me because
they didn't send me one first so that
that must mean that that you're asking
me and i'll probably get it wrong but
yes i am asking you and i hope you get
it wrong um
you talked with dak prescott yesterday
only one qb has more td passes than him
right now who is it
patrick mahomes ah man
where's the sound i like the sound
effect better than yours who is it it is
a russell wilson you should have known
that he's got 12. he's got 12 touchdown
passes that's right 12 touchdowns yes
i'm surprised my homes don't have more
yeah dummy okay here we go all right all
right dumbest nfl controversies okay
well
i mean i gotta start off with nipple
gate okay you remember that of course
yeah of course you would well of course
of course you would gosh you know it's
the super bowl and uh it was one of the
greatest games really one of the better
super bowls we've ever seen the carolina
panthers new england patriots brady
drove them down
uh to you know kick the the game-winning
field goal but a lot of the talk and the
controversy was about the halftime show
because of the wardrobe malfunction
justin timberlake ripping off the
you know i don't know breastplate
whatever it may be whatever it was there
to the cut whatever you wanted jackson
hey bro yeah whatever you want to call
it okay
call him she ripped off the clothes and
of course there was a wardrobe
malfunction there so that to me uh was
up there with one of the weirdest
dumbest controversies uh we we've had
that i can remember
that was back in 2003 pft had been
around for a couple of years at that
point
and and and that that was one that
lingered for a few days because look it
wasn't a wardrobe malfunction that was
planned when when it got the reaction
that it did then they came up with a bs
explanation after the fact but uh that
was a big deal at the time kind of
overshadowed what was a really good
super bowl number two win for the
patriots uh and the first of two in a
row so uh that's not a bad one that
wasn't on my list
um i don't know but yeah that was you
weren't even in the nfl when that
happened
after that yeah no i was uh that was my
rookie year my rookie year so i'm trying
to think was i 2002 you were you're
right no 2003. yeah it was the 2003
super bowl that was your right yeah that
was my rookie year all right um for me
here's one and this relates to the super
bowl when it relates to the
new england patriots it is spygate not
one but spygate 2. the allegation that
emerged in the boston herald on the
friday before super bowl 42 that the
patriots had secretly videotaped the
walk-through practice prior to super
bowl 36 of the then st louis rams it was
ultimately debunked it was ultimately
retracted
but it did and the patrons have never
made this excuse i think it created
enough of a distraction because the nfl
mobilized that day to investigate this
thing as the patriots are getting ready
to play the giants in the super bowl it
did knock them off of their axis just
enough i think to contribute to what
happened on sunday against the giants
and it was a huge controversy remember
matt walsh the former employee who who
had been talking about things that
patriots had done and then this report
comes out about spy gate 2 from the
boston herald and and again and look the
thing is there's always going to be
suspicion about the patriots because
they've been caught at least once
red-handed deflategate's a different
story altogether in my mind but uh it
was never substantiated it was never
proven but it consumed everything we
thought about and talked about going
into super bowl 42. yeah i mean uh that
that was definitely a big story you're
right about that um
yeah it's an unfortunate because you're
right there's nothing ever there
substantial to kind of verify it but
because it was the patriots and there
was some history there it seemed like
people kind of just ran with the story
so okay not a bad one by you um
i'm going to whoop your butt today
though i think i got you beat okay all
right what else do you got here we go
let's go how about uh jim jim harbaugh
and uh jim schwartz and handshake gate
okay that was a good one you know you
know i don't like jim harbaugh i love
john harbaugh i really do and i root for
him he's one of my favorite coaches in
football his brother jim however i root
for ohio state until he leaves michigan
and why don't you like jim because he's
a jerk and he was disrespectful and one
of my first interviews i ever did not
shake your hand i know he did worse than
that i asked him a question in one of my
first interviews i've ever done in the
business and i asked him about colin
kaepernick's contract situation the
third question i ever asked him and he
took off his mic and said tell your dad
i said hello and walked away let alone
100 other jerk stories i know about him
so it's all of that combined but either
way this was like you know evidence one
i mean first of all untucking it acting
like a fool as he's going out in the
middle of the field because he wants to
rub it on jim schwartz then he
handshakes him really hard kind of hits
him hard on the back uh just a meathead
buffoon move and then he's gonna tell
him to get out of his face jim schwartz
had every way to react the way he did
that was a jerk move by uh jim harbaugh
and i
yeah i mean it was fun and dumb and
everything
there's a backstory to this though yeah
and as i understand oh he's you know the
back story yeah well oh jim schwartz
said it was gonna be hard on a strike
season to get your team ready how dare
he make a point like that oh my gosh
that was so demeaning to jim
my understanding is schwartz was going
on and on about how basically you know
it's your first year's coach of the
49ers the lockout has wiped out the
off-season training camp is going to be
tougher it's going to be hard to get up
to speed you don't expect to do anything
it's just basically a wasted season
right and and jim harbaugh sat there
seething the entire time so he beats the
lions and you know he kind of gave him
the business hey hey hey jim jim was
excited right jim should have calmed
down a little bit more but schwartz is
the one that came at him uh and and bob
lang the 49ers pr guy got in the middle
of the middle of it and it involves the
49ers another handshake incident
involving the 49ers eight years after
yeah schwartz versus harbaugh all right
the next one for me um i and you know
what i'm going to go there i i think the
the bounty scandal from 2012 was this
one of the silliest and dumbest
controversies of all time because of the
fact that everyone was doing what the
saints were doing and greg williams had
done what he had done in new orleans
everywhere he had been right and the nfl
wanted to and think about what was going
on at the time the nfl was being very
sensitive to the issue of concussions
lawsuits were being filed nobody knew
how those were going to play out and i
think the nfl wanted to create the
impression that they are very serious
about player health and safety so we've
got this controversy we can turn into
something that that almost was sold as
another tanya harding and nancy kerrigan
type thing like somebody's waiting out
in the parking lot there's a bounty on
this guy like like there's a contract
out on him no these are guys who are
supposed to be playing within the rules
of the game and if they play
sufficiently aggressively within the
rules of the game and the opponent is
rendered unable to continue because of
the physical force that is applied while
utilizing a clean legal hit you get 200
bucks 300 bucks 500 bucks whatever right
the thing is everybody was doing it and
the nfl tried to implement a culture
change just like when steroids were
finally
eradicated by the nfl you didn't pick
one team and destroy them when everyone
was doing it you take it slowly you put
everyone on notice that times are
changing but they wanted to find one
team to hammer they hammered the saints
everyone was doing it and it really
stigmatized an organization
unnecessarily and i think it took them
several years to recover from that i
mean they may be on super bowl three
four or five right now if the 2012
season isn't turned upside down by this
decision to single out the saints for
something that everyone was doing but it
definitely hurt them i mean gosh it was
uh you know yeah greg williams
controversy distraction
sean payton you know that was the same
year he got suspended for the year as
well right and micro i'm correct with
that right i mean yeah payton was
suspended williams was suspended they
lost draft picks i mean i i just think
2012 yeah it was a totally lost season
for the saints and it took at least
their defense three years to recover
from yeah well it took away their most
valuable person in their organization
and that's sean payton i mean it's like
oh wait we took bill belichick away from
the patriots well yeah i would expect
them to kind of fall apart i mean that's
what happened yeah sean payton's special
he's the best coach in the building he's
one of the best coaches we've seen in
nfl history really so uh yeah i'm with
you two mike and it was going on on a
lot of teams in the nfl and it wasn't
meant for like we're putting a bounty on
to legitimately hurt somebody and knock
them out of the game and ruin their life
forever no it was just ways to motivate
guys have fun commodity in the
camaraderie in the locker room so i'm
with you there okay i'm gonna go with
elvis dumerville
facts uh fax machine uh mistake if you
remember that right i think it was a
2013 off season elvis dumarville the
denver broncos i love elvis dumourville
this is not his fault i was a teammate
with him in denver at one point but his
agent uh
obviously messed up what an idiot that
guy is okay but taking a pay cut from 12
million to eight million dollars they
try to fax in the signed contract by
elvis dumerville it gets there six
minutes late after the league deadline
it doesn't count so then elvis
dumerville becomes a free agent and that
ultimately works out better for him
because he gets to sign a long-term
contract with the baltimore ravens but
either way that had to be one of the
dumbest things i've ever heard the fact
that the agent like made elvis
doomerville have to go to like a kinkos
and fax it to the denver broncos is like
there's some of the craziest crap i've
ever heard
well and look that it's it's an example
and and whether it's football or
anything else
when you dance with that ultimate
deadline sometimes you're going to run
out of time and they waited up until
that last moment they negotiated a new
contract and and it all fell apart and
the broncos had to cut him because and
and there was a sense that maybe it was
some deliberate foot dragging by the
agent in the hopes the broncos would
blow the deadline oh yeah and keep elvis
dumarville because there was either a
big payment due or a big guarantee that
was going to come due and the broncos
said sorry we're not doing this we're
ripping up this contract so i think
there was an element of
this is just speculation but there may
have been an element of hey let's let's
hope we can accidentally get the broncos
to not terminate the contract and keep
the contract and kick in what's a better
deal for elvis doomerville all right
last one for me and and i'm surprised
this one lasted so long it's the antonio
brown helmet game i know i didn't want
to go there well well but here's why
here's why here's why we were led to
believe that this really was about
whether or not he can function in a
different helmet it's all baloney it's
all bs it was either attention or he
didn't want to practice or he just
didn't like being told no because the
moment that zenith yanked its
sponsorship he slapped on a different
helmet with with no
no questions asked whatsoever uh because
remember it was after he gave up his
helmet for good zenith to deal with
antonio brown they made a big deal about
it a week later that deal was over he
started wearing a different helmet he
wore it for one game and now he's gone
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports